Hello, hello, everybody!
Good morning!
Alright, so, yes, I don't sound dead inside right now.
It's cause, like, it's cause, like, Dad has been waking me up early in the morning!
So, no more, no more waking up at, like, 1220 before the stream!
Um, because, unless, like, I, unless I, like, pass out right after the walk.
So, uh, basically, alright, guys, I think I may or may not be spoiling Dad a little bit too much now.
So, I usually, okay, I keep my, um, sounds echoey.
Okay, I have, like, okay, I do have the soundproof stuff here.
Uh, I just haven't had time to hang anything up yet.
But, like, let me put a bunch of these.
Alright, so, I do have, like, these, um, echo absorber things.
On me right now.
Like, it's right here.
Uh, but I don't know where to put them.
So, I'm just gonna, I'm just gonna put some here.
I'm just, I'm, they're just on the floor.
They're, they're, they're, like, scattered everywhere right now.
I'm gonna put one over a, in the pile of plushies.
So, they're, like, they're, like, literally scattered everywhere on the floor.
Against the wall, against the table.
I have them, um, scattered everywhere at the moment.
So...
I didn't have time to hang it up because yesterday I fucking passed out.
Uh, I, I passed out yesterday.
So, I didn't have time to, um, to really, like, put stuff away.
Maybe I should put one against my wall.
Maybe that would help.
Maybe I put this over here.
It'd be less echoey.
Maybe, I don't know, where do I put this?
I can't put it against the wall in front of me because, like, uh...
Because, like, oh, man.
Uh...
Ooh...
Oh, fuck it.
You go on the floor.
You're gonna...
You're gonna be on the floor.
I can't be bothered right now.
Um...
But, like, I feel like by, by the member stream, we should have some fucking form of, like, acoustic barrier set up somehow.
Anyway.
So...
He's been, like...
He's been, like, a little bitch right now.
He's, like, super fucking spoiled at the moment.
Uh...
Because, like, I leave my bedroom door open.
Right?
So...
Because of that...
Because of that, every time I go stream, he just heads towards my bed and just sleeps in my bed.
Like, he usually never does that in the past.
He would, you know, go to his own bed.
But now, he's like, wait.
I can just sleep on her bed.
And then, like...
So, yesterday, I was like, alright.
I'm just gonna...
Um...
You know...
Go to sleep.
And then, I closed my door.
I would...
I didn't let him in.
I didn't...
I don't know.
He has this...
It doesn't help that I do have, like, staircases to my bed.
Because I...
You know, he's a wiener dog.
So, like...
Um...
I have staircases.
Because I don't want to fuck his back.
So, like...
Uh...
Fuck with his back.
Because he's too long.
Um...
So, like...
It doesn't help that he does have a staircase to my bed.
Um...
Anyway...
Uh...
So, like...
You know...
Uh...
I was doing some work stuff on my PC, and then I went to check...
I went to grab some water in the kitchen, and then I just...
This is what I saw.
I'll show you guys a photo.
This is like...
The first thing I saw.
I was like, are you fucking kidding me?
I was like...
This is literally...
The first thing I saw and he like dragged the body pillow and then he like dragged my pillow to like so he could like lean against him.
He's like, this is my bed now.
So yeah, so like this is what I saw today this morning when I was like trying to fucking grab water.
And I'm like, wait, just like, okay, the thing is, uh, all right, let me show you another picture.
So like, this is another thing I saw in my I'll show you the other picture I saw too, which I was like, are you fucking kidding me?
I saw this, I was like, this I saw like a few days ago.
So this one, you know, he is, he's like, you know, it's not, it's like, okay, I was just like, what the fuck are you doing?
Yeah.
So like, he's so fucking spoiled now.
He's so.
fucking spoiled.
And because like, last night, I was like, Okay, I want the bed to myself.
Like, yesterday, I was like, Okay, all right, I dad, I want the bed all to myself.
Like I, I, I just leave.
Because like, two days ago, he started sleeping in the middle of the bed while I'm trying to sleep.
So like, he's like trying to sleep in the middle of the bed.
I was like, No, no, no.
Well the bed is bad, what's your problem?
I was like, okay, we can't let you do that.
Because like, I need a sleep in this bed, and you're a fucking furnace too.
So I was just like, move.
And then he refused to move so I have to like, sleep at the like edge of the bed, because he wouldn't fucking move.
So annoyed.
So like, yesterday I tried to kick him out of my room, And I was like, No, you sleep outside.
Now.
I want the whole bed today.
Like yesterday, I was like, there's just like, I want this entire bed.
And then it was like midnight.
It was midnight.
And he just kept barking.
He's like, no!
And then usually you ignore the dog because you don't want to give him the idea that the more he barks, the more likely you're going to open the door.
But he kept barking for 10 minutes.
I was like, I was so scared.
I was going to get a fucking noise complaint because it's midnight.
I was so scared.
I was like, I don't want to get kicked out already.
And then I was like, I give up.
After like 10 plus minutes, I'll give up.
And I opened the door and he ran straight.
Like the moment I opened the door, he ran straight to the bed.
And he just like, it was like one second.
I literally opened the door and he ran right there.
And just, and just like underneath my, and then he fucking crawled underneath the blankets too.
He was like, ran there, crawled underneath the blankets and was like, he's like, sleep time.
It was like, sleep time.
I'm like, are you fucking kidding me?
And then quiet, no sound.
And then, and then, okay, this is the worst part.
Today, like, oh my God.
Today, he like fucking woke me up.
Cause like, he was like, it's time to feed me.
And I looked at the, I looked at my phone.
I was like, it's 7am.
Please, I just want to sleep two more hours.
Dad, I just want to...
Jokey Amber Doge, I just want to sleep at least one or two more hours.
And he's like, no, feed me.
And then, okay, so like, he's allergic to everything, right?
So like, I'm, I'm waiting to...
I usually, after every walk, I would like, wipe his paws.
Because like, because he's allergic to everything.
He's allergic to like, numerous kinds of trees.
And like, he's allergic to like, various things.
He's allergic to nature, basically.
But his allergies makes him itchy.
So like, usually after every walk, I would like, I have to like, wipe his paws and everything.
So yeah, he's allergic to...
He's...
This is how fucked up his genetics are.
He's literally allergic to maple trees.
And I'm like, that's Canada.
For those who don't know the history of Dad.
He...
One of his allergies is maple trees.
And we literally live in Canada.
So...
It just makes him like, more itchy.
And...
And the thing is...
The thing is...
Like...
Usually after every walk, I have to wipe his paws.
So like...
Because like, he's been scratching a lot too.
But I...
I don't have like, pet friendly wet wipes.
Because like, I don't...
I don't want to use like, normal wet wipes.
Because I know like, some of it is like, really bad for dogs.
So like, for pets.
So I'm like, waiting...
Like, it should be delivered today.
So I haven't been like, wiping his paws the last couple of days.
I've been getting like...
I've been wetting...
I mean, I've been trying to like, get like...
I've been like, getting some Kleenex and like, wetting like, tissue.
And to like, clean his paws.
So like...
But I don't think it's like, working as well.
But yeah.
Like, today I should be getting the dog...
Dog friendly wet wipes.
And...
And so like...
So he's been scratching a lot lately.
And I've been helping him like, scratch as well.
Anyway...
So...
So like, he woke me up today.
He woke me up today.
And he's like...
Feed me!
Or he's scratching himself.
He's like...
I'm so itchy!
I'm like...
And then I have...
And then...
He's so spoiled.
To the point where like...
I was like...
I can't.
I need to sleep one more hour.
It's way too early.
It's way too early, dad.
It's...
It's way too fucking early.
And...
And so...
I just like...
I just ignore him.
I turn around.
And then...
He fucking jumps over my body.
To the other side.
To where I turn away from him.
And then he like...
He uses his nose.
And like...
To like...
Move my hands.
To his body.
To be like...
Now scratch me.
And I'm like...
Are you fucking...
He literally uses his nose.
He'd be like...
Underneath my hand.
To like...
Make it so that it's positioned.
To where his like...
Belly is.
Or arms.
He's like...
Yeah.
Scratch me.
Now.
And I'd be like...
You fucker.
And then...
I would scratch him.
And they're like...
Okay.
I'm done.
I need to sleep.
And then I turn away.
I like...
Turn away again.
And then he like...
He jumps over my body.
And does the same thing.
And...
And he's like...
You think you can get away from me?
And be like...
Scratch me.
And he does it.
I like...
Like...
I turn around.
Three to four times.
And he kept doing it.
I was like...
Are you...
Are you fucking kidding me?
I was just like...
Please.
Let me...
I will feed you.
And I will scratch you more.
Just give me one more hour.
I swear to fuck.
I need one more hour.
Anyway.
I was scratching him.
I was like...
I kept scratching him for him.
And I did like that he was scratching himself.
Anyway.
I'm done.
Uh, so yeah, he's been like super fucking spoiled now.
And like, I am definitely I'm going to like, I feel like I might hire a I might hire a personal dog trainer, because he's getting a little bit too naughty.
He's his he he thinks he's he basically thinks he's alpha right now.
This tiny ass dog.
This is a tiny ass dog thinks he's alpha at the moment.
So like, I'm I'm thinking of hiring a personal dog trainer to like, to like, teach him his place again.
It's because like, I don't know.
Ever since I ever since I moved to this new place, he's like, I own this place.
He's like, he's like, now that we're in a new location, this is my kingdom.
Oh, my God.
And then he's so okay.
The thing is, when he's like, when he's like leashed, he's so aggressive towards other dogs.
I don't understand.
But like, if you like at dog parks, he's okay.
Like at dog parks, he's okay.
But for some reason, whenever like I take him for walks, he's super aggressive to other.
He's like, this is my.
My grass, like, like, there was like, there was a lady that was walking your dog and like one of them was like unleashed and it was tiny.
It was like those toy poodles, those tiny like toy poodles.
And then.
And then he was like, he was like, he's like, what are you doing?
Like, walked up and he's like, but I was like, oh,
he's like, no, don't you dare get close to me.
And then like, and then like one guy, like he walked up to one guy and then, you know, I thought he was being friendly.
He walked up to this one guy.
This was not today, by the way.
This is like two days ago.
He walked up to him and then he was like looking at him.
He's like sniffing him.
And then like, obviously that guy thought he was going to pet him.
Like he wanted, like that guy thought he wanted, he wanted pets.
And then he like put his hand down and then, and then dad was like, oh.
Yeah.
I was like, I'm so sorry.
I'm so I'm so sorry.
I know he gave you the look.
I don't know man
He got baited.
He got baited so hard.
And we were in the elevator.
That was the worst part.
Like we were in an elevator too.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Being a beta to the wiener dog.
Betty thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
No, you don't understand.
Wiener dogs have to be like one of the most like aggressive dogs.
In the world because they were literally trained to hunt badgers.
Those little tiny fuckers were trained to be...
Have you guys not seen the fucked up video of two wiener dogs tag teaming a snake?
That shit was crazy.
I... I remember seeing that video and then the fucking two wiener dogs were flinging the snake around like a toy.
And I'm like, holy shit.
Like and then ripping the snake in half.
Like literally like...
Like they were playing tug of war on a fucking snake.
And I was like, Jesus fucking Christ.
That shit was crazy.
I was like, oh my God, that's dead.
That's...
Yeah, they're very...
They're very vicious.
Like I try to not give him any stuffed animals because like...
Like it never works.
He always rips apart every stuffed animal I gave him.
And the cleanup is such a bitch.
You guys haven't seen it?
Oh my God.
No.
Okay.
Like I would say like trigger warning because...
That shit was gory.
Like...
Like at first, like, you know, the snake's body was...
Was full intact.
And then later on, it's like...
You see bone.
And I was like...
And I was just like...
Oh my God.
Like...
And then after like 30 seconds, bones.
And I'm like...
And you look up like...
I think like...
Dash hound.
Or sorry, dachshund.
I don't know how you call it.
Dash hound.
Like dachshund.
Dachshund versus snakes or some shit.
Oh my God.
Like...
It's so fucked.
It actually is so fucked.
But yeah, he's...
He's getting very spoiled now.
And...
And I'm definitely gonna have to...
I might...
I'm...
I'm thinking about hiring a personal trainer to like...
Like...
Calm him down and remind him that...
No, he does not own this apartment.
It's cause he think...
It's...
I think it's cause like...
I moved to a new place.
So then he's like...
This is mine now.
So like...
That's why he got way more spoiled than before.
So...
So like...
So I was like...
No, you have to train him.
Doki.
But what time?
I...
That's the thing.
I don't have time right now.
I'm so behind on so much work.
I would train him...
If I have the extra time.
The thing is...
I don't.
And I need him to cut it out.
I need him to stop doing that.
I...
I need him to stop.
Yeah, but like...
The personal trainer will give him the basics.
And then...
Like...
We'll fast track the basics.
And then...
And then like...
I don't know.
Then the personal trainer will be like...
Alright.
You gotta do this and this.
And then I can do it.
I can't do...
I can't do the starting process.
I need...
I need a trainer to like...
Get him back into the starting process.
And then I can be like...
Okay.
Now.
Now...
And then I swoop in and take all the credit.
That's...
He's actually...
Absolutely.
Oh my gosh.
Anyway.
So...
Another update.
For those who don't follow me on Twitter.
Uh...
My Five Nights at Freddy's VOD, the Into the Pit got age restricted.
So...
Basically, you have to be 18 plus or older to watch that VOD now.
I...
I think it's the title.
I think it's the...
Is that the Bite of 69?
I think that...
I don't know.
I think it's the title.
I have no idea why it got age restricted.
Anyway.
The thing is...
I appealed it.
I appealed the...
Uh...
I tried to appeal it.
And then it got instantly rejected.
Like the...
Like after like five minutes, it got instantly rejected.
And like...
It's not like I appealed it at like...
Like prime YouTube hours too.
I appealed it at like...
At like 11 PM.
And then...
So I messaged my YouTube guy about it.
They haven't responded yet.
I don't know if they're like at work yet or like...
They're busy at the moment.
Um...
But yeah.
It got...
I like how it waited a day before age restricting it.
I literally got the message that it's like...
Um...
It got age restricted like last night at like around 8 PM or something.
So...
I thought that was funny.
I was like...
Why?
I'm pretty sure...
Like...
FNAF is such a popular...
It's such a popular series.
I am not the first person to make that joke.
There's no fucking way.
I cannot be the first person to make that joke.
Like...
Is that the bite of 69?
It's such a...
It's such a like 13 year old humor.
It's like...
Oh my god.
The 420 blazed 69.
Like...
Oh my god.
Just...
I'm just like...
How's that?
How's...
How's that 18 plus?
That's literally high...
Middle school to high school humor.
I don't understand.
Anyway...
Um...
I...
I asked my YouTube guy to be like...
What the fuck happened?
Like...
Do I need to change the title?
What do I do?
Uh...
No...
The PG...
Even in PG 13 things...
People make the 69 joke.
It's not...
It's not fucking 18 plus shit.
Come on...
It's like...
Oh my god.
69...
420...
Oh...
Anyway...
It's time to play Dungeonborn.
So...
Um...
There might be issues with this game.
I'm not sure yet.
Because like...
I got hit by the anti-cheat thing.
So...
Um...
We're gonna see.
All right.
Whoa.
Okay.
Am I okay yet?
I'm okay now.
It was just the start.
All right.
I think the funny thing is that you have to be 13 or older to play Dungeonborn.
I confirm.
I am...
13 years and older.
All right.
Why is it not...
Oh my god.
Don't tell me.
This is...
Is this one of those games where...
Oh...
I think it is.
Okay.
Give me a...
Guys.
It's one of those games where...
It doesn't...
Are you serious?
Okay.
I know what's wrong.
These are one of the...
These are the games that require you to...
You can only stream it in a window capture.
God, I hate that.
I hate that...
I hate that when games do that.
All right.
Tutorial time.
So, basically, Dungeonborn is...
Oh.
Is it mining Bitcoin right now?
Okay.
Let's see.
This is basically Dark and Darker.
But easier.
That's from what my friends told me.
This is Dark and Darker, but like easy Dark and Darker.
Okay.
Let's just do high.
We don't...
It's like...
These graphics are not going to improve.
Anyway.
Okay.
Voice chat.
Push to talk.
All right.
If it's push to talk, I want to...
Push to talk.
Okay.
It's T.
How do I adjust...
Control...
Whoa.
How am I lagging?
How's my mouse lagging?
That's actually crazy.
Screenshot on dead?
Really?
Holy shit.
Okay.
Oh.
No camera sway, please.
Textures high.
Sharpness.
Let's see.
Is there a motion blur?
No motion...
As long as there's no motion blur, that's good.
So.
Okay.
I like how it tells me...
You're like, oh, my God.
I could see, like, the file location.
Yeah.
It's like, oh, my God.
The file location name isn't Doki.
Yeah.
It's not.
It's my first dog.
All right.
Let's see.
What is the...
Yeah.
I usually name my PCs after my first dog.
Okay.
So, like, I think Guy for no motion blur.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Did I tell you guys?
One of the...
God.
This is so embarrassing.
This is not...
The name is one of my dogs.
So, I've owned, like...
Like, I've owned, like, lots of Wiener dogs over the years.
Because, like, ever since I owned my parents and I own...
Oh, my God.
Our first Wiener dog, we've always...
We've...
Is there something in front of me?
I'm in the settings because this is multiplayer.
I heard something.
Am I going to get out of settings and then I'll be dead?
Like, where's the controls?
I'm trying to...
Is it automatically T?
I was trying to find controls.
I can't find any control.
Okay.
We don't need to look at our reflection.
All right.
Anyway.
But one of the Wiener dogs...
I used to...
I used to own was called Gilbert.
And I'll let you guys try to figure out where Gilbert came from.
Is there no sense?
This is the whole reason why I fucking came here.
Because I need to try to find the sensitivity.
I'm trying to find the sensitivity.
Oh, my God.
There's no game sense?
Oh, God.
Okay.
All right.
Just so you know, it's not Gilbert.
It was not inspired by Gilbert Godfrey.
Just so you guys know.
Whatever you guys might...
All right.
Okay.
This is defend.
All right.
Okay.
I still take damage.
All right.
So, it's basically darker and darker.
Okay.
It's in the main menu.
All right.
Oh.
It's basically dark and darker.
Wait.
It is basically...
Oh, my God.
Ew.
Even the animation.
That's me.
Oh.
Look at those sick abs.
I'm so dehydrated as fuck.
Wait.
It's literally...
This is literally dark and darker.
All right.
We'll grab some clothes.
Big sword.
Is this loot?
Oh.
I didn't see that.
Okay.
Did I loot this?
Oh, wait.
No.
This is the same loot.
Okay.
All right.
Same loot.
The combat is better.
Well, to be fair, dark and darker has a very bad reputation right now because of the whole it's free, but most of the good stuff is only available if you pay for the game.
So their reputation isn't looking so good.
And then at least Dungeonborn isn't in the middle of a lawsuit, too.
So like...
Dungeonborn isn't actually...
Oh, shit!
It's a little sad.
All right.
Whoa.
Hello.
Charge?
Oh.
Boom.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
And it's free.
Boom.
Oh, he's blocking.
This is not fair.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
I can jump dodge.
Oh.
JK.
I cannot jump dodge, guys.
All right.
Let's see.
Am I?
Yay!
Yeah.
It's...
And then I heard there's SBMM, too.
So like when you first start out, you're going to play with other players that first started as well.
So they're like actual SBMM.
Okay.
E is the charge.
I need to remember that.
Block.
Counterattack after successful dodge.
Wait.
Okay.
Parry.
Block right before being hit.
Oh, there's parry.
There's perfect counterattack.
What the fuck?
Okay.
You guys don't see it, but like...
Yeah.
It's like gear-based matchmaking.
So you have no gear.
You're going to fight other characters with no gear, which is pretty interesting because, you know.
Okay.
So, uh...
Press 2.
Oh, okay.
We're a win.
Oh, shit!
That's not what I wanted!
I wanted...
Okay.
We're a win.
Oh, okay.
I'm so dead.
Am I really going to die in tutorial?
Let's find out.
Let's...
Okay.
Let's heal.
All right.
Because I know like Dark and Darker didn't have gear-based matchmaking.
Nice.
We need that.
All right.
Spin to win.
Okay.
Shoes.
All right.
We're good.
We're okay.
Oh, what's this?
Okay.
Nothing.
What are they worshipping?
What is that?
The fuck were they worshipping right there?
Stupid goblins.
All right.
I am the goblin slayer.
I wonder how many smurfs...
Let's find out.
Okay.
Blocked it.
Shoot this.
Oh, shit.
He shot that.
Wait.
I thought I staggered it.
Okay.
Never mind.
I thought I actually staggered that.
So I was like, shoot this.
Okay.
Using my bandage.
I feel like everything will be okay.
Oh, okay.
That heals a lot actually.
I was not expecting that.
I wasn't expecting that to heal so much.
Am I in the right area?
Oh.
F.
The shield looks fragile.
I mean, it's made out of wood.
Just spin?
Spin!
I heard some classes are like mega busted too.
So it'll be interesting.
All right, guys.
It's time to teach me which classes are super fucking busted.
Because it's like unbalanced as fuck.
Is there stuff in these?
Hello?
Chest open.
Is there anything here?
Ooh.
Nice.
I like that.
I like loot.
Give me the meta.
What is the meta?
I need to know.
Do I not have shoes on?
No, I do.
It just sounds weird.
It just sounds like I'm barefoot right now.
Is the wizard cracked?
Who are you?
Hello, concert.
Friendly?
Are you friendly?
Oh.
Can he open doors?
Oh, no, he can't.
Wait!
Can I cheese this?
Friendly?
Hello?
Can I cheese this?
Whoa.
Idiot.
Fucking idiot.
That's fucking right.
What you gonna do?
Nothing.
That's right.
Oh, wait!
You can't do anything.
It's couldn't do anything.
Easiest game of my fuckin' life!
That's fucking great!
Can't even open doors!
You stupid fuck!
I don't need to learn anything!
I have a door!
That's right!
God didn't give you opposable thumbs!
What the fuck you gonna do?
Nothing!
Holy shit, that's so stupid!
How much HP do you have?!
Holy shit, I'm bringing a big boy!
Oh, this only works with the small, okay.
I'm bringing a big boy!
That's fucking right!
God didn't give you opposable thumbs!
Oh nice, he got a horse.
Nice, okay.
That was easy.
That was so fucking easy.
Holy shit.
And they say this game is hard?
I have doors!
Ooh, that's spooky.
This looks very spooky.
Whoa!
Whoa.
Is this the escape portal?
What is?
Bye!
Goodbye!
The shield in game, a door.
Yay!
Alright, who was...
Okay, cryo, DK, and druid.
Okay, but like, which was like...
Okay, cryo, death knight?
Holy shit.
Cryo, DK, and druid.
Wait, can I be a bear?
Transform?
I can be a panther?
Panther?
Wait, um, but like, in game.
Okay.
Oh, it is.
Oh, cryo and..
Wait, is that it?
This is just panther?
What if I wanna be a bear?
Last seen.
Someone's threat is designated.
Promise for dealing shadow damage.
I can't be a fucking bear?
But like, Baldur's Gate taught me that druids can turn into bears.
It's a bear!
And then they can... fuck things.
I don't...
Okay, let's see.
It will be dark.
Okay, Death Knight looks cool.
A terrifying warrior that strikes fear into enemies.
And at close... wait, you didn't see the Baldur's Gate cutscene?
The first thing they ever showed in Baldur's Gate...
was when, like, that guy turned into a bear.
And then the... the... the... the other... the main character was like...
Whoa!
And then, like, I... I was like, what the...
I was literally the one... the only thing I know about Baldur's Gate.
I was like...
And the vampire guy.
The emo vampire guy that everybody loves.
And I'm like, what's so great about him?
Why is it all skelly, guys?
Why is it all skelly, boys?
The fit... yeah, the bear form stays on.
Hahahaha, hahaha!
Hahahahahaha.
Alright, let's see...
Uhhhhhhh...
You're right, he's not emo, he's a goth kid.
The vampire guy is a goth kid.
Alright, ummm...
Spellcaster who constantly restricts and weakens enemies on the battlefield.
When coordinate well with teammates they can create an advantage...
advantages.
And it has soul energy replenishing by killing creatures and absorbing their soul.
AoE...
I don't like that.
I don't.
Okay.
Feeling a small amount that I'm pulling the target to you.
Oh, it's this one!
Fire a spectral hand at the target.
I feel like if to do that, I actually have to be good at the game, so I'm going to get the soul shroud first.
I feel like I actually have to be good at the video game to do this part.
I can't believe it.
It's only panther?
There's no bear form?
Okay.
Sustained area damage to tournament nearby foes.
Oh, I get both?
Oh, there's E!
Oh!
This is all my abilities!
I see.
Okay.
E, absorbing souls.
One soul resists me.
I have to kill an enemy, generates...
Oh, okay.
That's a lot of stuff.
All right.
I'm going to be good at this.
This is going to be the death knight.
It's like a homage to the bark knight.
This will be a death knight.
Okay.
You think they'll be friendly?
Damage relies on soul energy, lacks mobility.
So I have to kill things to get soul energy.
All right.
Oh, my God.
I can have hair!
I don't like that.
Oh, my God.
It can be a balding...
That's so fucked.
That's actually so fucked.
Not only...
Not only am I a death knight, but I'm a balding death knight.
You know what?
Yeah.
I'll be a balding death knight.
Ooh.
A balding death knight that went through a phase.
You want to know how I got these scars?
Yeah.
You know what?
Phase.
Okay.
I'll do that.
And then...
Let's see.
Oh, yes.
I guess I...
Actually, do I want to have scars?
Do I want to have scars?
Nah, there's no scars.
All right.
Helmet?
I don't have a helmet.
The setting...
No.
I want everybody to see my hair.
Okay.
All right.
Wait, how many letters can I do?
Five?
Five to eleven.
Okay, guys.
Any name suggestions?
Wait, I like that.
Okay, somebody had a good name.
Okay.
This is a good one.
I like that.
You don't see it now, but like getting started.
Okay.
Magic.
I don't need to know that.
All right.
Rest easy.
Okay.
So you guys will figure out my name soon.
You guys will...
You guys will figure out my name soon when you can see it.
Okay.
Heirloom.
Alchemist.
Merchant.
Uh.
Can you buy my stuff?
Equipment.
Buyback.
Wait.
How do I sell?
Oh, sell.
Sell.
Uh.
Unleash the terror.
Wow.
Are these equipment?
New skills and nature event.
There's so many things.
Oh, I get it.
I got, I got key potions!
Okay.
Yes, I'm the doker.
It's that's me.
I am the doker.
I want to put my stuff away.
Shop.
Oh, oh, this is like actual shop shop.
Oh, wait, that's cool.
This looks like, this reminds me of Diablo, the new Diablo, the, not the new, sorry, the last Diablo game, with the cosmetics.
The one who dokes.
Yeah, trade.
Okay, I'll beg for stuff later.
I don't want to...
I don't want to bring any potions.
I feel like I can...
If I lose an, you know what, I don't want to bring, if it's like SBMM, where it's based on the gear, I'm not gonna bring any gear.
I'm not gonna bring any of my gear.
That's fine.
Let's see.
Alright, now I'm naked.
Alright, I'm gonna start, okay start.
Casual...
Casual, casual... okay, casual, casual, I guess this is rank, Mythril Order.
Wait, what's that?
Wait, actually, competitive.
Wait, there's competitive?
Uh, Mythril Order.
Uh, what's does this mean?
What's the Mythril Order?
Because it's different from competitive.
Let's see.
You know what?
I'm ready.
Let's start.
Please check your loadout.
I've confirmed my loadout.
I'm naked.
Oh, it's like the ca- Oh, the cavern run!
I see.
Alright.
Oh, I need to like, adjust my sensitivity.
I forgot.
Settings.
Okay, mouse, keyboard.
Oh god, I need to adjust that.
I hate that so much.
Okay.
Aiming method.
Hold.
Click.
Move forward.
WSD.
Weapon set.
Voice chat.
Okay.
Nope.
Okay, apparently you can't use mouse button.
That's cool.
Literally, the one thing I wanted and I can't use was your inventory.
The fuck?
You have nothing?
Alright.
It's dark and darker time.
I'm dungeon-boarding it right now.
I'm dungeon-boarding?
Why am I- Did I literally spawn on top?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, apparently I spawned at- I spawned at the top.
Alright.
Ooh, pants.
Ooh!
Hello.
How do I get down?
Is that a person?
Guys, I don't think they're friendly.
How do I get down?
How do I- How do I-
Okay.
Okay, this is fucked.
This is actually fucked.
Get down.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh my god.
We gotta get rid of the tentacles.
Get down.
Alright.
Wait.
My soul energy.
I can use souls.
Soul!
I did it.
Okay.
Elixir.
Alright.
I already lost half my HP.
That's cool.
I'm doing my best.
Whoa!
Oh, I have shoes.
I have shoes now.
Oh!
Let's see.
Drink the elixirs first, but you can't- Oh.
Uh...
Which one is the elixirs?
Is this- Which one is the elixir?
It's two elixir?
I can't tell.
Which colors are the elixirs?
I want to take everything.
Oh, okay.
I drink.
Whoa.
Whoa!
Wha!
I killed ghosts!
You're a ghost!
Why can I stab ghosts?
Oh, God.
That was spooky.
Bro!
I- That's it.
I'm angry.
Oh, I don't have enough souls.
Never mind.
I can't get angry.
Oh god.
Okay, I'm understanding the patterns.
Alright.
We're figuring it out.
Oh, it's a sphere.
Oh, they're all ghosts.
Oh, I don't like this room.
They're all ghosts.
Whoa!
Okay.
Wow!
Wrong room!
Oh my god!
Okay.
Get out of here.
This is not the room I should have went to.
Okay.
There's a giant rat.
Goodbye.
Alright.
Not going back there, that's for sure.
Okay.
That was the wrong room.
Why is this scary?
And then fucking dark and darker.
How is this...
How is there more monsters here?
Alright.
Doink.
Are there any friendlies who want to be my friend?
Anybody want to be my friend?
Hello?
Any friends?
Oh.
It looks like a...
Are there any doors?
Guys, I don't think he's friendly.
Guys, I don't think he's friendly, guys.
Guys, I don't...
Wait.
Can you go downstairs?
Oh.
Wait.
I could cheese this.
Oh.
I cannot cheese this.
He has a rock.
I...
I cannot cheese this.
He has a rock.
I...
I don't want to piss up.
I don't...
I'm not gonna try and piss him off.
He can throw rocks.
Use paper dookie.
Doki, use paper, guys.
I'll open door.
Door time.
Hello Little Goblin.
Where's your family?
You'll never see your family!
You'll never see... OH SHIT!
You'll never see your family... OH SHIT!
You'll never see your family again!
That's fucking right.
Alright.
Grab some heals.
Real quick.
Alright, nice.
Yay!
Alright, more gold.
Oh god, we're at the portal home.
I wanna go home.
Close the door.
Oh, hey there.
Hello?
Oh, I hear somebody.
Is that...
There's somebody else.
Oh my god, there's this guy that's killing everybody.
Three escape portals have appeared.
Oh, I can't put on anything.
I'm gonna be naked.
Oh.
I'm scared.
Okay.
Wait, why can I...
I hear somebody outside there.
Oh.
Okay.
There has to be a portal near me.
That's fucking right.
You can't shoot this.
Oh, you missed, bitch!
That's fucking right!
Alright.
Killed your son and now I'll kill you.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, okay.
Hello?
Oh, there's so many portals.
Oh no!
The Resident Evil-ness!
Okay.
Where are the portals?
Oh!
Okay.
Uh...
Um...
This is a thousand.
Wait, I want a thousand.
Ten...
Okay.
Math.
Portal?
Any portals?
Where the fuck are the portals?
How can there be no portals near me?
Oh, is there loot here?
I already got that.
Is there?
Hello?
There's so many escape portals!
But yeah, I don't know where they are!
Oh god.
There has to be one near me.
Is that an escape portal over there?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Please, I don't wanna die!
I don't wanna die!
That's it!
I'm angry!
Sold!
That's fucking right!
Get sold!
Alright, nice.
That's good.
You got sold.
Is that a portal?
Oh, is that it?
What the fuck is that?
I don't know what that is.
I don't need pants.
I want this.
There's a blue circle?
Guys, I'm blind!
You know that!
What's blue?
Blue!
Where the fuck is the color blue?
I can't see!
I'm stuck in this hallway!
I've been going back and forth in this one goddamn hallway!
Oh!
No, that's not blue enough.
There's the rat.
Maybe it's here.
There's too many ghosts.
I don't wanna deal with ghosts.
Alright, I'm gonna go this way.
The only enemy there is...
Oh, I should drink this.
I'm gonna drink this.
And I'm gonna drink this.
I have no idea if this will help me.
That's fucking right.
What you gonna do?
Shoot me?
That's fucking right.
You missed.
I'm angry.
I can't find blue.
That's right.
You have no rights.
You're a goblin.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, did they hear that?
Am I like literally the only person left alive?
Oh hey!
I get pants now!
Yippee!
I have pants!
Oh.
Oh, he killed so many people.
Woah!
Fun Friendly!
Please!
Please don't...
Oh my god, there's somebody behind me!
Oh!
Please!
I'm scared!
I just wanna leave!
Okay.
Oh, come on!
Oh, fuck!
That's a rat!
That's multiple!
This is where I die!
This is where I die, rats!
Oh!
Oh shit!
Too many rats!
Leave me alone!
The blood moon is rising!
Wait!
I see so many!
I can't leave!
Oh my god!
Please!
No!
I just wanna leave!
Don't hurt me!
There's so many rats!
Please!
No!
You fucker!
You're so mean!
Oh my god!
I hate you!
You...
I hope you never find me in Ducking Portal!
I...
I've got the fucking...
There were so many rats!
I got so...
I...
I can't...
Where are the portals?!
I...
I can't... couldn't find any portals!
Where the fuck...
I...
I actually was begging...
I was screaming in my...
Stop!
I...
Every time I tried to go to a new area...
It was just rats!
Where's the portal?
How is he finding...
Okay, I need to know...
I need to know if he finds a portal...
I need to know...
If he'll die...
Are you fucking kidding me?!
There's a portal right there!
That's not fair!
That's actually not...
How does he find a portal?!
I...
I couldn't find a portal anywhere!
And there's two...
And there's two portals!
This is absolutely bullshit!
Everything doesn't...
go for Doki!
And...
Nothing ever...
goes for Doki!
This is why I got those cars!
This is...
exactly why!
This is already...
This is how I got these cars!
...
I can't believe it.
How does he not find the rats?
Why do I find rats?
This is not fair!
Oh my god, Chaney, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The rat king has been slain.
This is actually bullshit!
This is so bullshit!
I found every rat possible!
This is not fair.
I even... I even... I even tried to talk to them.
They didn't even care!
They didn't even care.
I was begging for my life.
I was... voice chat is team only?
Wait, I can't even beg for my life?
That's... Approximity voice is what makes it so fun.
Oh my god.
I can't even beg for my life.
That's why he ignored me.
I was like, please spare me, concert.
I can't believe it.
I begged for my life but it didn't even matter.
It didn't even fucking matter.
Nobody heard me.
I cried into the void and the void did not care.
Oh my god.
That's why I didn't hit back!
I thought... I thought... I thought he was just an asshole.
I was begging for my life.
I thought he was an asshole.
He just was good in here.
Okay.
Alright.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Alright.
Here we go.
Everything... Oh shit!
I don't wanna fight the rats.
Oh my god.
Don't let the rats get me.
Don't let them get me.
Alright.
Okay.
Here we go.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Maybe I'll be friends.
Alright.
I don't... Not this way.
Maybe there will be people who want to be my friend.
You know?
That's the great thing about multiplayer.
Right?
Alright.
Let's see.
Get this elixir in.
Oh!
Look at all this loot!
I can't wait to...
I can't wait to give this loot to the first person that kills me!
What?
Did you guys hear that?
This is third party time.
Hello.
Oh my god!
That's fucking right!
I'm coming in!
That's right!
Oh my god!
He's turning into a pet thing!
Fuck you!
Alright.
Let's steal his loot.
Secure my loot now, bitch.
My loot now.
Thanks for killing them, you loser.
.
Let's see.
Yippee.
Oh, you want a round too?
Fucking hell.
You want a round too?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Friendly?
Oh, he's not friendly!
He's not friendly!
Whoa!
Friendly?
Okay.
Alright, let's go.
Woo!
.
And that's how we became best friends.
Woo!
That's how we became good friends!
You go, Panther!
You go!
Alright.
There's no way, there's no way he'd kill me.
He killed the rats!
He killed the fucking rats!
There's no way!
Whoa!
Yeah, that's right.
Beat the shit out of you.
What's he gonna do?
Stab me now that...
Whoa!
Look at him go!
Wait, he's so strong!
Holy shit!
It's like he knows what he's doing!
Nice.
My loot now.
Guys, we have to work together.
Oh, I hate Resident Evil-ing this.
Okay.
Uh... Oh my god.
I hate this.
I hate trying to Resident Evil this.
Alright, yeah!
Go, guy!
Go!
You got this!
I believe in you.
Yippee!
Oh, look at this loot!
Alright...
Look at that, I made it.
We're best friends after I tried to kill him.
Now we're best friends.
Oh, shoulder.
Good.
Alright, let's see.
Where do I have to go?
He's got this!
Look, he's a fucking panther!
Look at him go!
Oh my god, he's so smart!
Oh my god, he's so good at this game.
I'll let him see.
I'll let him have that.
See, I'm a good pro.
Oh, he's gonna let me have that?
Nice.
Oh, let's open this chest.
Guys, guys, guys.
This game is so easy.
Go, furry, go!
You got this!
What a guy.
Don't worry, I'll give you light!
Look at that!
I gave you light!
This is like my pet cat.
Oh shit, there's also a mimic.
Whoa!
What?
What did you mean?
You brought him over!
Oh wait, there's a chest!
Alright.
Let's see.
What the fuck?
What the fuck is going on here?
Alright.
I think I have enough loot.
Alright, it's time to find our escape portal.
It's time to find our escape portal, guys.
Ooh, gloves.
Oh, I don't have enough inventory.
Okay, we don't need this.
This is clearly bad.
500 gold?
Holy shit, I'm rich!
Alright, let me grab my torch.
Alright.
We gotta find our escape portal.
Wait, there's something over here.
What's this?
Oh, it's like a resurrection stone?
The fuck is that?
We're so rich, man.
Okay.
We gotta find...
We gotta find a way to leave.
Okay, let's get rid of him.
I'm contribu- Wait, that's a rat!
Okay, let's get him out of here first.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Oh shit!
That's fucking right.
What's he gonna do?
Hit me?
Wait, where's my buddy?
Wait a minute, where's the buddy?
Where'd the buddy go?
Wait, I'm alone!
Holy shit!
Alright.
See, I told you, he would never betray me.
Oh, let's get him out of the way.
Alright, we're fine.
See, everything is- Bro, look at those dodges!
Holy shit, he's actually caving!
What the fuck are those dodges?
Alright, let's see.
Let's grab a silver.
Where the fuck are the portals?
It says two...
Two, three, four portals.
Alright.
Are there any portals anywhere?
What a gamer!
Guys, why did I not be a druid?
Did you not see the moves he did?
That shit was insane!
That shit was crazy!
He's a- Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Crazy guy.
Whoa!
Okay.
Alright, there's more!
There's more for you!
Don't worry!
You got this!
Oh, that's a lot more!
That's a lot more!
Don't worry, I have more people for you, druid!
Don't worry, druid!
There's more!
Okay, there has to be a portal here...
Please, I just want one portal!
Oh, this is where I- Like, where I first spawned in.
Where the fuck are the portals?
I swear...
Oh, I brought more!
You got this, druid!
You're so good at this!
I'm so efficient!
You got this, buddy!
All right, bye.
I didn't find a portal first!
The portal is number one priority.
It'll be fine.
Look at him.
See?
Look at him go.
He's fine.
He's alive.
Maybe there's a portal here.
See?
I'm contributing.
You said I'm not contributing.
A shadow portal!
Is that the portal that goes like deep down?
Druid!
Druid.
Druid, get over here!
Wait, is my druid dead?
Druid?
Whoa!
Druid, get over here!
Druid!
Druid, go aggro!
Yeah, you got this, Druid!
Alright.
Whoa!
Druid, keep aggroing!
I believe in you!
Druid, there's this other guy!
Whoa!
Boy!
One more!
Okay.
Yippee!
Alright.
Tyrone Kitty.
Thanks, Matt.
Stop!
Is he gonna find the exit?
Is he?
Of course I left it.
What the fuck?
He's late to take.
Look, I am like the moral support.
Look, he's literally full HP!
He's literally full HP.
He's fine!
I've escaped.
That's all that matters.
I should have stalled until like...
What the fuck?
How did he know?
How did he ins...
That's fucked!
No, I should have baited him.
I should have waited until like 30 seconds left or some shit.
And then took the portal.
And...
I should have done that.
Just to see what happens.
Oh my god.
There's Moose?
How is there...
What...
What does the Moose do?
Oh my god.
What the... How does he still have inventory space?
Are the Moose...
Are the Meese...
You guys didn't know.
Um, Meese is like the plural form of Moose.
Are the... Are the Meese like...
Wait, they're evil Meese?
They're evil Moose?
They're like evil Moose.
How does he still have...
Wait, there's werewolves?
Wait, fight the werewolves, Tyrone!
Tyrone, do it!
Fight the werewolves!
Or are you a little bitch?
Little... Little bitches don't...
Little bitches can fight werewolves.
Come on!
That's right, Tyrone!
Fight the werewolves!
Don't be a little bitch!
That's fucking...
Oh shit!
That's fucking right!
Yeah, 2v1 him!
Yeah!
Actually, it's Moosey.
Come on, Tyrone!
You got this!
Use your panther powers!
Watch out for the were...
Are you running like a little bitch?
Tyrone!
Come on, Tyrone!
Oh!
Can't even kill...
Oh shit!
Can't even kill a werewolf.
Alright.
Wow.
Guys.
That was an easy game.
Holy shit.
Maybe I am a gamer.
Maybe...
Maybe I am a gamer, chat.
I don't know.
I...
I feel like a gamer just then.
Alright.
We can sell this.
Leather.
Orb.
What do I do with...
Okay.
Uh...
Oh!
I can craft consumables.
Sell.
Plus will.
Uh...
Sell.
Oh!
Okay.
Is that better than what I have?
Yeah.
Okay.
That's blue.
And then I'll sell these two.
Alright.
And then grow...
Let's put some stuff away.
Eh...
We can sell it.
Alright.
Nice.
How do I make...
Oh!
I can get 20 for free?
Wait.
We don't need that.
Uh...
Let's grab...
Oh!
We can make healing potions!
Let's go.
I might...
Might as well.
Let's go.
Oh!
Shit!
Nice!
Alright.
I don't need anything else.
I literally just need healing potions.
Uh...
Where's my inventory?
Where's my chest?
Oh!
There it is!
Alright.
Uh...
Stash.
I'll grab two potions and then I'll stash everything else.
Nice.
Alright.
Wait.
Can I actually have friends?
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I have an idea.
How do I get frie-
Can I actually have friends?
Let's see.
Alright.
I need teammates.
But you gotta be good at- Okay.
Wait.
Guys.
My.
My requirement is that you gotta be level 20.
Okay.
Alright.
I'll be level 19.
Level 19.
Sorry.
Level 2.
I'm level 3.
No.
Look.
I- I lowered- Guys.
I lowered my expectations here.
Guys.
Here.
Alright.
Out of this.
Guys.
Alright.
Level 18.
That's- That's as low as I can get.
Guys.
Level 18.
Wait.
How hard is it to actually grind levels?
Actually.
I actually don't know.
How hard is it to grind levels?
I don't think I can get high levels in this game.
Chat.
No one is showing up.
No.
I can't get destroyed?
There's no way.
How would I get destroyed?
Yeah.
You get pasta boots- Oh.
It's not that hard.
Alright.
Okay.
Level 10.
That's- That's the lowest I can go.
Guys.
I don't deserve to be in level 10 lobby?
chat I think I I can I can fucking I can I can live in the level 10 Lobby Okay, I'm sorry.
Yeah, but I don't want to disappoint random people.
I don't mind disappointing dragoons, but like I don't mind disappointing dragoons, but I don't want to disappoint random people
Come on guys.
I promise you won't lose your loot chat.
I promise I Promise you guys won't lose your loot chat No, it's because you know the expectations going in what the game is gonna be like guys You can't say that you know what the game is gonna be like when I'm on your team those randoms don't You already go in with a set expectations on what the game is gonna be like.
Oh Shit I have a private message.
Oh shit Ben Ben bash gene.
All right.
What's your level four level four I Mean you are a higher level than me.
All right, okay You're in You're in Laugh Tyrone Kitty you're fucking in That's it Laugh Sorry, bro.
Tyrone kitty.
Okay, the other guy.
All right Alright, um Tell us why you deserve to be on this team Laugh Laugh Laugh Laugh Laugh Laugh Alright, if he can make his case on why he thinks he is qualified to be on the same team as Tyrone Kitty, then maybe he gets the chance.
I play more than you!
You're literally one level higher than me!
He's like... I play more than you.
He's one level...
You are literally one level higher than me.
They're not wrong.
They're right though.
That's like... that's like... that's like 15 more minutes!
Know your place level 3.
Alt...
I said... I said...
Join on your main, coward!
He literally wrote... alt account.
Alt account, are you fucking serious?
That is actually crazy!
That would be too easy!
That fucker!
Join on your main or you don't get to be on...
Tyrone Biggoo!
Or you get replaced!
His main is Tyrone Kitty!
Would it be funny if that was...
Wait, is this... is this Tyrone?
No, this is... Tyrone is his own person.
Alright...
No one... No!
No, no!
I need this guy to join on his main.
I need to know.
I need... I need to know.
I need to know what his main is.
Tyrone Healing.
Bro, how many Tyrones are there?
There's Tyrone Kitty, Tyrone Biggoo, Tyrone Kitty, Tyrone Ice.
How many Tyrones does this Tyrone have?
He's... I'll try to get... get into the lobby.
Bro, he's gonna try and fucking stream-sync.
He's a coward!
He's gonna stream-sync if he...
Fuck it.
He's actually gonna stream-sync because he's a coward!
Not on your main!
Coward!
Alright.
I don't... I don't need Bastion.
I have Tyrone balling.
He's gonna ball with me.
Alright.
We're good.
Come on, Tyrone.
We don't need him.
I've perfected the way of all Tyrones.
Alright, Tyrone.
We don't need him!
You and I!
We are a team!
Tyrone the champion!
We'll show them!
We'll show the Dowdies!
He mastered all elements of Tyrone.
Oh my god.
With the power of Tyrone.
Nobody can stop us now.
Are we really the only people in this lobby, Tyrone?
Wait, it's two out of fifteen.
Where are the other adventurers?
Tyrone, we're gonna fucking kill all the other adventurers.
Tyrone be balling.
Wait, it's just me and Tyrone!
There's no other babies?
The fable.
The last Tyrone.
Hahaha.
Don't worry, Tyrone.
We'll show them.
We'll show those Dowdies.
Me and you.
Me and the last Tyrone.
The last Tyrone bender.
You could've had a third.
No, that guy was a coward.
He didn't go on his main.
That's right.
Couldn't even snipe me.
If you were on your main, you could've gotten on this lobby.
They're all scared of Tyrone.
Oh my god, Tyrone!
We're gonna be so jacked.
We're gonna have so much stuff.
This entire lobby is just you and I.
I don't believe him.
Oh my god.
Wait, it's literally just you and I, Tyrone.
Does nobody have the inventory that I have?
A pretty good inventory.
There's less players and duos.
There's people with less friends.
Tyrone!
Look at these people with...
Oh.
Oh my god, it's a 2v2.
Tyrone, you got this, right?
You can 1v2, right, Tyrone?
Right?
Can I hurt my friend?
Wait, I can, right?
Is there friendly fire?
Oh no, Tyrone.
It's us against the world.
1v2.
1v3.
Wait, is there friendly fire?
Wait, is there?
Is there 1v3?
Wait, yes?
Oh, okay.
Okay, Tyrone.
We might be 1v3-ing.
Alright, Tyrone, we got this.
Tyrone.
You and I.
Those fuckers won't know what hit them.
We got this.
Oh.
I'll never die.
Let's go.
Let's go, Tyrone.
We got...
There's the...
Where do I go?
What the fuck?
Where the fuck?
Oh, there's a bat.
Wait, we should fight a werewolf.
Oh my god, it's the fucking moose.
Don't worry, I got the bat.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, Tyrone.
I got this too.
Why the fuck?
The moose.
Hey, but there's his.
You guys.
We got this.
Okay, nice.
All right, I got the gold.
Don't worry, Tyrone, I got you!
Don't worry, I saved your life, Tyrone.
We're in moose land now.
We're in...
Wait, there's another moose.
Did you see that?
We're in fucking Canada.
Oh my god, I told you Canada's dangerous.
I knew it.
We're in fucking Canada now.
Okay, what's this?
Ooh, lion statue.
Don't worry, I got you!
Got you, Tyrone!
Don't worry!
Oh shit!
Oh!
Oh, I'm worrying!
I'm worrying!
I aggroed him!
Don't worry.
Alright, my turn.
Look at that.
Be sure you stay away from this area.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
The dangerous lands of Canada.
Hope the RCMP doesn't show up.
Alright, nice.
Looks like a cemetery here too.
Whoa!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, WHOA!
There is tree, guys?
Okay, not gonna lie, Dungeon Point has so many more enemies to deal with.
Like, getting darker and darker are just like goblins and skele- goblins, skeletons, and like, zombies.
There's like, fucking tree guys, rats, bats, Canada.
Fucking werewolves.
There's so many enemies here.
Ooh!
Ooh, loot!
I wanna fight that other team.
Wait, is that boss?
Tyrone, is that boss over there?
Is that one of those- Oh no, there's zombies too!
Whoa!
Okay, don't worry, I got you.
Don't worry, Tyrone, I'm here to help.
Wait, I got hit!
What hit me?
Don't worry.
Don't worry, I'm here to save you.
Ooh, more shield!
Wait, can I put this on?
Ooh!
Better gloves!
My big brother!
That's like stuff I can make money out of.
Alright.
Don't worry.
I got these zombies.
Pew!
Alright.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Oh, it's the RCMP!
The RCMP is here, Tyrone!
Tyrone, the RCMP knows I've been grave robbing!
Okay, he's running...
Wait, where is he?
Oh, he's walking away.
He's walking away.
Okay, I can grab the...
I can get the zombies though.
That's right.
106.
Oh!
I fucked up.
Wait.
Tyrone!
Tyrone, he's slowly following me!
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Don't worry.
Got you!
Whoa!
Oh!
Axeman, not hap- Whoa!
Okay.
Okay, I think I...
Okay, I think I should not have aggro.
I aggroed Axeman!
Don't worry.
Soul time!
Wait, he's so tanky.
Holy shit, he's so tanky.
Woohoo!
Woo!
Got you.
Alright.
What is he doing?
He's just bashing his head.
Is he?
Okay.
How much HP does he have?
Oh!
He's dead.
Nice.
That was so easy.
Oh, that's for you!
Me?
Okay.
That was so easy.
Alright.
Nice.
Let's find...
Let's find those two.
We gotta show them who is the better duo.
Boink.
Yeah.
He fucking boinks his head.
What the fuck?
Okay.
I haven't...
I haven't killed...
I haven't, like, accidentally hit Tyrone yet.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
Tyrone, we gotta find him.
We gotta find that duo.
We gotta beat their ass.
Wait, Tyrone knows where the duo is?
Don't worry, I got you.
Tyrone, why are you getting away?
Alright.
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh, wait.
Do I have pants?
I do.
Oh, wait.
It does more.
Alright.
Nice.
I got pants.
Oh, I want arrows.
Alright, Tyrone.
Let's see.
Oh, wait.
I'm, like, a little hurt.
Let me...
Guys, I'm a little hurt, guys.
I mean...
Oh, shit!
I'm gonna...
Please check inventory.
Is that better?
Wait, that's not better.
That's just money.
Okay.
Is there fall damage in this game?
This is such a big map.
We literally have not found the duo at all.
And this map is actually huge.
Holy shit.
No?
No!
I mean, I could have been doing this this entire- Oh my god, I could have just jumped off.
I can't believe it.
I didn't know!
I thought there was fall damage!
Cause there's fall damage in Dark and Darker!
Tyrone, we have to find the duo, Tyrone!
I don't care about loot!
I just wanna kill!
Tyrone, come over!
They must be in the castle!
Where else could they be?
I can't believe gravity is not real, chat.
They must be in the castle!
We have to kill them!
We have to show them who's boss!
And it's us!
What the fuck?
You're so fast!
This should be illegal!
How are you so fucking fast?
Oh shit, there's so many rats.
Oh!
Tyrone, what is this?
What if they come for me, Tyrone?
Wait, Tyrone, I'm not as fast as you!
You're literally a cat!
Oh shit, what have they said?
We have to find them!
That means they're here somewhere.
Wait, no, that's the boss area, Tyrone.
Why are you taking me to the boss?
Where the fu- That's- This is Goblin Sharpshooter!
Tyrone, why are you taking us to the boss?
Tyrone!
Tyrone, what are you doing?
Wait.
The boss is dead.
Wait a minute, they killed the boss?
OH!
THEY DIDN'T KILL THE BOSS!
THEY DIDN'T SPOT IT!
What are you doing?
Oh my god!
Look at that movement!
Look at that fucking movement though!
Oh, they must be here!
The door is open!
The door stopped being open!
They must be here!
Wait, these are- All these doors are locked!
Don't worry, I got you!
I know you're still alive somewhere.
Okay, we found a por- OH!
OH!
Okay, we found one of the porters.
Don't worry!
I'm moving!
That's it, fuck this.
OH NO!
You can't get me!
Soul time!
That's right.
That's right, you can't kill me.
I have the power of soul.
Alright.
Where could- Wait, this door is open!
No, that's just a gate.
Wait, no, that's just a gate.
That's just another portal.
It's JK.
Where could they be?
They must be alive somewhere.
Where are you?
I know you're still here!
This map is huge, Tyrone!
Where could they be?
We just need to kill one guy!
I'm here to bounty hunt!
I literally need to bounty hunt one guy!
Oh shit.
That's a rat.
Oh, I got you.
We found so many porters!
He has a bounty on his head and we're here to claim it!
We need a blood sacrifice!
You know what?
Fuck this.
I can use the big sword.
I ain't scared.
All these doors are closed too!
That's the hard part!
All the doors are closed!
So I can't find that- Whoa!
I can't find that one guy!
And he hasn't escaped yet too!
So I know he's alive!
I know you're alive!
You must be hiding somewhere!
You have to be hiding somewhere!
I can feel you!
Don't worry.
What the fuck?
Why don't they attack back?
Is that like a...
A druid thing?
Where they can bait people?
Oh no!
The blood moon is rising!
And we have yet to find them!
That one guy!
You have to escape sooner or later!
Oh!
Wait!
He might be here!
They're all running away from- They're all running away to somewhere!
I think he's here!
You're all walking somewhere!
He has to be here!
Oh no!
The blood moon is still rising!
You must be here!
Where are you?
I know there's still one guy alive!
The hunt for the last guy!
Oh no!
There's one minute left!
It's okay, Tyrone!
We know where the portals are, right?
There's no way!
This door is open!
He might- Wait!
Is it because I was here?
Wait, was I here?
Am I going in circles, Tyrone?
Am I- No!
He escaped!
And he had to- He just escaped!
He- He actually escaped!
That- Fucker!
It's a bomb!
We hunted him for 20- We hunted him for 20 years!
And the man escaped!
It's a bomb!
And I didn't get the bounty!
I just wanted the fuck- I didn't care about the loot!
I just wanted- I just wanted to kill him!
Oh my god!
That fucker!
Tyrone!
You can't die!
The doker has escaped!
Don't worry, Tyrone!
I believe in you!
You can kill them in 40 seconds!
What are you playing?
I couldn't even find my food!
I- I couldn't even- We went through 20 rooms!
I couldn't even find my food if I wanted to!
He disappeared!
I can't believe it!
We literally needed to find this one guy!
And he left!
He escaped!
That's why I'm level 4 now, bitch!
Oh my god!
I'm so mad!
I can't believe it!
I can't believe he got away!
I don't need this!
I don't need that!
Get the shit away from me!
I don't need any of this!
Oh, I can use arrows?
Oh, okay.
I don't need shiz.
What if I just bring arrows?
Alright.
999 bolts?
For 25 gold?
Give this shit to me!
Oh!
Oh, never mind.
One piece doesn't- I thought- Okay, I thought it was like 25 gold for 999.
I- I guess it was one- One bolt is- 25.
Alright.
One bolt is 25.
Okay, that's less impressive now.
Alright.
Wait, can I do the thing in- Can I do the thing in like- Uh...
Okay, let's see.
Purchase my- Can I trade with people?
Auction...
Uh, you need the auction house listing- I have to go to the store?!
Okay.
Good.
Sell, purchase.
Oh, so like these are like things you can buy.
Okay.
Uh...
I can buy gear rolls?
What the fuck is gear rolls?
The fuck is that?
Is it in the merchant?
Cloudy life essence.
Mithril dice.
Not be lost the next time you enter.
Is it?
Is it this?
Oh, it's in the tray?
And it rolls- you buy the gear and it rolls right- Oh!
These?
Is it these?
Traveler sword.
Traveler shield.
Alright, is it these?
Oh!
Wait, that's interesting.
Alright.
I'm gonna try- Wait, what do I have?
I'm gonna try armor.
Uh...
Do I need to pay more?
Or can I just pay- If I purchase a map, does it increase the- Does it increase the stats?
Or does it just give me a second armor piece?
Does it just give me a second armor piece, chat?
Oh, okay.
I'll just buy one.
Alright.
What did I get?
Where is it?
Oh, there it is!
Alright.
What is this?
Oh, shit!
Plus six will!
Sounds nice!
Sounds pretty- That looks pretty good.
Alright, let's get pants!
You know what?
I have the money!
Let's fucking do it!
Let's get some pants on!
I deserve pants!
Alright.
Nice.
I'll get it.
Oh, shit!
Plus six stamina!
Let's go!
Alright.
Now we'll grab some arrows, too.
And then we'll put this away.
And this away.
We don't need any of that shit.
Okay, let's grab some potions, though.
Alright.
And we'll put that away.
And then this away.
And then- I'll sell these later.
It's time to game.
Alright.
Does anyone else want to be our bounty hunter?
Our mission is to kill the other people!
Man!
Put me in?
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh, shit!
I got DPS on deck!
Alright.
Let's go!
We're the bounty hunters!
We're gonna hunt some- We're not gonna kill regular people!
Regular moms!
We're here to hunt some bounties!
Let's fucking go!
Let's go!
We're gonna- Everybody, ready up!
The Doker is here to hunt some bounties!
Got Tyrone- Tyrone healing!
Damn!
Alright, we got Box as the DPS, Tyrone as the healer, and I'm the captain!
The Doker and my goons!
Don't worry, team.
We're here to kill- to kill the lobby!
Oh!
Wait, three!
Wait, that's us!
Wait, that's just us three!
Wait, how are we gonna kill the lobby if it's just us three?
Alright!
If it's just us three, Tyrone versus Box!
We're gonna- We're gonna watch Tyrone and Box duke it out if it's just us three.
We'll have a bet!
We're gonna- we're gonna fight- You know that area with the rat and two knights?
We're gonna head there, okay?
If it's just us three, we're gonna head over there, and then, yes, the healer versus Box.
I believe in Tyrone!
I believe in him, he can heal himself!
Wait, no, there's three other people!
Guys!
JK!
JK, look, there they are!
Oh my god, these guys are fucked!
I see a wooden shield!
Oh my god, it's a wizard!
Okay, what kind of hat is he wearing?
I'm a little concerned.
From the distance I see it, there's something off about this wizard and his hat.
I'm like- I need to get closer!
I don't know how I feel about this hat.
Oh my god, no!
Oh god.
Oh!
I should not have went closer!
That is a lot worse!
Oh!
Oh no!
Alright, where's your third?
Where's your third?
Wait, does he have good loot?
Let me check his- No, his inventory is invisible!
You fucking coward!
I can't believe it!
Alright.
I believe in this Tyrone and box.
We got this!
I needed to know his loot to see how fucked we are, but like, I believe.
I believe in our team.
I have my arrows.
We have DPS and heals.
What can go wrong?
We're back in Canada.
Why do we keep spawning in Canada?
Why?
I don't understand.
Why do they keep taking us to Canada?
Oh shit.
Scary trees.
Oh, 166.
Oh, this is like...
Oh, nice bats.
It's my hometown.
Oh my god, look at them go.
Holy shit.
Box!
You should be able to dodge that box.
You're level 20, man.
Nice.
Oh, I get back my arrows too.
That's nice.
I get back my arrows after.
Okay.
Back on home- Oh shit, werewolf!
We got this!
Guys!
It's a werewolf!
Holy shit, he's spinning!
Look at him go!
Go, box, go!
Don't worry, I did 133.
The infamous Canadian werewolves.
Oh shit, my arrow.
You got this, box!
I hit a headshot!
You got this!
What loot do we get from a werewolf?
Wait, that's it?
Not even a lot.
Alright.
Yeah, you guys gotta be careful in Canada.
There's a lot of werewolves down here.
Alright, nice.
Headshot.
I mean, 166 is not bad for a headshot.
And I get my arrows back too, apparently.
Right?
Do I get two arrows back?
Yeah!
If I hit it, I get two arrows back.
Okay.
Ooh, wait.
What is...
Let's do defense.
I like that.
What are you kidding?
Is that bad?
Nice.
Okay.
What?
What did you drop?
Ooh!
A helmet!
Oh my god!
Nice.
Alright guys, we gotta find those three.
Alright guys, come on.
We're gonna head up.
It's time.
It's time to head up into the castle we go.
We have to hunt some bounties, boys.
As I figure out how to get up.
Alright.
It's time to hunt some bounties.
We got this.
We're here to kill.
We're here to claim our bounties today.
Damn.
Alright.
I'll grab these chests.
Ooh!
That's some good-ass gold.
Okay.
Maybe you're right.
Maybe...
Maybe sword is better.
Where could they be?
They have to be in the castle.
Like, where else could they go?
Alright, if we killed them, I want to see you two fight.
This goddamn mosquito!
Get down!
Alright.
Where should we go?
Alright, Tyrone!
Oh, shit.
Wait.
Tyrone!
What do you smell?
You might not be a druid right now.
But I know.
I know you still have that dog in you.
Alright.
Let's see.
You can never take the dog out of you.
Where could they be?
They must be, like, on the other side.
They must be in the castle.
They usually spawn...
If we spawn in that side, they have to spawn in the castle.
Anything good?
Oh, there is.
Thanks for opening that for me.
Oh, shit!
Don't worry.
I got him.
Alright.
Tyrone, I need some heals.
Thank you, Tyrone.
Tyrone healing.
Alright, we should clean this up.
Let's clean this up for our fight later.
Or your fight, and then we'll do a bet.
With the dragon.
Holy shit!
That was so fast!
Wait, they're that easy to kill?
Alright.
Time to kill these knights.
Don't worry.
I got you guys.
Boom!
Wait.
Oh, I'm doing the same damage as, like, a bow, but with faster DPS.
Okay, you guys are right.
The bow sucks.
The bow actually sucks.
Can I open it faster?
Alright.
I don't remember if they were originally open.
Oh, wait.
These doors are open.
Okay, they were supposed to be open.
Right?
No, they destroyed the doors.
Where would they be?
Guys, we are not going out.
Okay.
Alright, Tyrone.
Do you smell them, Tyrone?
We failed our last bounty hunt.
We gotta get them this time.
Oh, hey.
Go.
Nice.
What do you smell?
What do you smell with your...
with your nose?
Where do you think they're at?
Tyrone smells them.
Tyrone knows.
He knows.
He can feel them.
Let's kill the baby.
Let's tag team on this child.
That's fucking right.
That's what we're gonna do to them.
Sniff them out, Tyrone!
Sniff them out!
Yeah?
What do you smell?
What do you smell, boy?
What do your kitty ears...
What do your kitty ears and nose see?
Let's kill this guy first.
Pew!
Alright.
There's so many escape portals.
But yet, no bounties.
Okay, we found another portal.
There's so many portals.
Jesus Christ.
Alright.
Where were these portals on my first game?
Geez.
Okay.
Are they outside?
No, they're not outside.
Wait, unless...
Whoa!
You thought you could scare me?
I have ears.
That's fucking right, ghost lady.
Okay, they're not out here.
Unless...
Wait, unless...
No, they're still not there.
They haven't escaped yet.
Could they be here?
This is what your ears are telling you?
None of the doors are open though.
Oh.
Rats.
There's rats behind me, guys.
There's rats behind me.
Okay, there's this door here.
How about this door?
If I open every door, there has to be an open door somewhere.
Okay, not there.
Tyrone's just a healer!
Tyrone!
No!
We left him!
Quick, Pox!
Pox!
Distract him!
Oh!
No!
We let the healer find them!
I didn't abandon them.
I...
Look, it's not I didn't abandon them.
We just...
Look, it was 1v2.
They don't understand!
They're dead!
I can't believe our healer!
Our healer found all three of them at once!
I can't...
I can't believe our healer was that unlucky!
Oh shit, he's spinning!
Oh, he's on fire!
You got this, Pox!
This is it!
This is your story!
Oh...
And the tea!
That wasn't me, though.
Look, this is exactly why I had to leave.
This is exactly why.
If I didn't leave, that could've been me!
Guys...
Guys, that wasn't my fault, guys.
Like...
I had to make a really tough decision there.
Guys, I had to make a very difficult choice there, guys.
Like...
It was such a difficult choice, everybody!
So...
Like, it's not my fault!
It was just very unfortunate!
That that happened!
Like...
Like, I didn't wanna abandon them, but what else could I do?
In that scenario?
What else could I have done?
Guys... What...
I was like, I'm not being a healer no more.
Wait!
Pox lost all his armor!
Pox...
No...
Poor Pox...
If only somebody could've...
If only we could've avoided that...
If... Oh... What else could we have done to avoid it?
Guys... What could we have done differently?
Guys...
Oh... Tyrone's stab!
Oh no, Tyrone's getting angrier!
He's...
He's getting angrier now!
He's about to stab somebody!
Oh no...
My poor...
My poor lads...
He's so...
He's so poor now...
Guys...
It's okay...
It's okay... This time...
This time, we will get our revenge guys... We were just unfortunate, our healing counted all three of them by themselves...
That was just like...
What else could we have done?
Let's go to Sinner's End...
This seems fun...
Sinner's End?
Let's get there!
Two stars?
I think we can do that...
Duck, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you!
Note to yourself, do not get stuck in a horror film with Ducky...
Guys, are you ready?
Tyrone Kitty, we got it!
We need you!
What do you mean?
It was 2v3!
We lost our healer!
What could we have done?
Guys, we have to kill at least one person.
That's our mission today.
Guys, team!
We can do this!
We can kill one guy!
Look!
A bounty hunter knows when, when, when like, we need to run!
This is a new area!
This area looks cool!
Alright.
Are there another...
Is there another bounty?
Alright, guys.
If we can't find anybody, we'll have a 1v1 between you two.
It'll be the fight of the century.
What do you mean?
Somebody has to tell...
Somebody has to get reinforcements.
You don't just...
Guys, you don't just like go in and have everybody die.
We always need...
We need a survivor to tell the story.
I survived so I can retell the great story between Box and Tyrone.
And their noble sacrifice for the cause.
They sacrificed themselves for the cause.
It was so noble of them.
And I was part of that fight.
I was their part of the fight.
And then Box was like, you!
Go!
I will...
I will take on all three of them so you can make your escape.
And I was like, No, Box!
No!
We can't do that!
It's all of us and nobody!
And then Box was like, no.
No, Doki.
Somebody has to...
Somebody has to live.
And I...
I tried.
I tried to stop Box and Tyrone.
I was like, no guys.
I will not leave you behind.
But they pushed me out the door.
They pushed me into the portal and sacrificed themselves for the adventure.
I tried to stand my ground.
But they pushed me out.
Guys!
They pushed me out of the chamber into the portal.
Are we role playing or what?
They literally pushed me into the portal.
I tried to stand my ground.
Alright guys.
Looks like you two are fighting each other.
Let's find a battleground.
Let's find an arena for you guys to fight.
It's just you and I.
Ow.
Don't worry.
I'll bring your loot back.
Whoever dies.
Actually, no.
The winner brings the loot back to the other guy that dies.
Let's find an arena for you guys to fight in.
Whoa.
Wait, what's that?
Is there stuff in here?
Oh, I can use the gate.
Oh, wait.
He didn't fight back?
What?
I didn't know that.
Alright.
I didn't know you can fight back.
Guys, where the f...
Is this just a dungeon?
Is there an arena for you guys to fight in?
I want to find an open arena like that rat area.
It sucks.
Oh, wait.
Maybe here?
Oh, this could be our arena.
Is this a good arena?
Tentacles.
Oh, no.
I should drink some more potions.
Let me grab some more potions.
I miss Tyrone healing.
Whoa!
What hit me?
Oh, shit.
I'm not doing so well.
Okay.
Oh my god.
There's like these little mosquitoes too.
Alright, I'm okay now.
Okay, I need to grab some...
Oh, shit.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, that's an eye.
Alright.
What is that?
Oh, there's no more healers.
Nice.
What does this do?
A resurrection stone?
Oh, does this resurrect you guys?
Okay.
Come here.
I got this.
Alright.
We're fine.
We're fine, guys.
Alright.
Let's find an arena.
Oh, what's this?
Ooh!
Okay, it's time for Tetris.
Alright, guys.
You guys ready to fight?
One person... one person here.
One person stand here.
And the other guy kill this first.
Alright, let's get rid of everything first before we kill any...
before you guys fight.
Let's make sure the arena is...
is clean.
Alright.
Get rid of him.
See?
I'm contributing.
I'm making...
Alright, guys.
The other person stand here.
Okay?
You stand there.
Alright.
Let me make a pool first.
I'm gonna make a...
Whoa!
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Get rid of all of these guys.
Alright.
I'm gonna make a pool.
Fox versus kitty.
Alright.
Fox goon versus kitty goon.
Who will win?
Fox kitty.
Alright.
The moment...
The moment I throw this torch, you fight.
Okay?
The moment I throw this torch.
Oh, it looks like kitty goon is winning.
Whoa, box.
I don't know, box.
It looks like kitty seems to have the popular appeal.
Alright.
Three.
Two.
One.
Fight!
Whoa.
Look at them go.
Tyrone will not beat me.
What is this fucking...
Whoa!
Holy shit!
And it does nothing!
Oh, and then kitty freezes him!
He's sending lightning over!
Kitty is going into panther form and running away!
Like the little bitch he is!
Fox is scouting it out right now.
Kitty hasn't done barely any damage!
Kitty, what the fuck is...
Alright,
guys!
Stop!
Stop the fight!
I didn't stop the fight, guys!
Circle!
I didn't get in the circle!
Alright, guys.
I didn't realize there's a zone.
Fight has paused.
Pause the fight, everybody.
We need to get in zone.
Guys, we...
I didn't realize there's a fucking...
There's a fucking zone here.
Okay.
Alright.
I don't know, guys.
I feel like Box won after all that third party by the zone.
I feel like Box is gonna win, too.
And the zone wins!
No, but...
The house wins in the end.
Wait, this is the same sorcerer from that dark and darker.
Looks exactly the same.
Wait, wait, wait.
What portal is that?
What's that red thing?
Wait, what's that red thing in front of me?
What is this?
What is that?
What?
There's like a red... Oh, is it this?
What is that?
Whoa.
Hey there.
Alright.
Oh, is that a bug?
Oh.
Yeah, but on my map, there's like a red portal, so I was like confused.
Is it this?
I'm like, what the fuck is that red portal?
Alright.
Guys, I don't know.
It feels like...
It really did feel like, you know...
Kitty might have lost.
I don't know.
Oh, that's what it was.
Oh, wait, how do you get inside that?
How do you get inside that?
What is this?
Nah, run it back.
Alright, guys, we're gonna run it back.
Alright.
Right here.
Alright, Kitty, you stand here.
Hmm.
Box.
Rematch.
Box, you stand over here.
Box.
Alright.
We have... Still have time.
The moment I throw this, we start the fight.
The rematch.
Three.
Two.
One.
I'm grabbing this.
Whoa!
The lightning strike!
The first lightning strike!
Oh, what's Box gonna do?
They're just looking at each other menacingly.
What are they gonna do?
Are they...
Are they just...
They're just...
And Kitty runs off!
And Kitty leaves!
But joke's on you!
It was just a joke!
He's back for more!
And he's gone.
Tactical.
And he's gone!
And he's gone.
Oh my god!
But Box doesn't care!
He's here for more!
He's bloodthirsty.
Oh, we gotta head over there.
And Kitty leaves again!
Goodbye, Kitty!
And then Box is also retrieving.
And I'm gonna open this portal.
And he leaves!
And I'm like...
You two better be fighting!
What the f-
I...
I had fuckin' just...
I
can't...
I can't believe he just did that!
I can't believe he...
I...
He just ran off and took the portal?
Right and left!
Right in front of us!
We got a bot in the escape!
I think that's payback for...
I'm pretty sure that was payback for what we did earlier.
For the first fight, I'm pretty sure.
The brave is war.
That has to be... that has to be... only zero escape portal left?
What do you mean?
That was literally only one escape portal?
Holy shit!
Oh my god, I can't believe that happened!
Bro, I can't believe that happened, bugs!
I can't believe people leave us like that!
Oh my god, we don't have an escape...
portal.
Oh my god!
I can't believe it!
That's actually crazy!
Do you think that was like... do you think that was karma for what we did earlier, chat?
Do you guys think that was karma for what we did earlier when we left him to die there?
No way, right?
No way, man!
There's no way!
Okay.
Oh no.
Fox, I swear!
Fox, I swear to god, Fox!
Fox, please!
Don't do this to me, Fox!
I swear to god!
Yay!
You have won!
Alright, bugs, it's just you.
It's just you and I.
Oh, he's just going to die with the...
Fox, you have so much to live for!
Fox!
You have so much to live for!
You don't, Fox!
Fox, don't!
Don't do this to yourself!
Find the portal!
There's still hope!
There's still hope for you!
He has nothing left to live for.
Fox, I believe in you!
Despite everybody voting against you in the poll, there's still hope!
You got this!
I believe!
You can finally exit!
There's no way!
There's literally two more portals!
There's so many portals for you, Box!
Look!
There it is!
See?
I believed in Fox.
Box, I believe in him.
I 100% believed in this man.
Let's go!
I can't believe Kitty fucking took the portal!
I can't believe it!
That fucking coward!
I can't believe he did that!
That's actually crazy!
Holy shit!
Kitty!
Okay!
Okay, Kitty!
Explain!
Explain yourself, Kitty!
Kitty doesn't play by your system in your sick games!
Tyrone's scared!
That's getting unfair!
Guys, he was scared.
He was scared, okay?
Understood!
Honestly fair!
God, bro!
It's understandable!
Holy shit!
That was fun!
It's alright!
We're gonna call it here!
That was a good game to end it on, guys!
That was actually...
That was fun!
I had a great time!
Poor box!
Box absolutely got...
That box lost so much!
Oh my god!
GG's, guys!
GG's, Dragoons!
Oh, man!
We might not...
We might not have been able to hunt any bounties today, but...
That was really fun!
I had a great time playing Dungeon Born and like...
Just fucking around in Dungeon Born today!
Pour one out for pro!
I feel like Box was the one that lost the most out of all of us.
Oh my god!
He lost 40k!
Oh, stop!
Stop that, bad guys!
Only 40k, guys!
It's alright!
It's just the 40k!
It's okay!
It's okay, guys!
He can get it back!
I believe in him!
I believe in Box!
Guys...
Alright, guys.
But that was so fun!
Thank you, everybody, for watching!
I do have a second stream.
I do have a second stream today.
It's a member stream and we're going to be doing a watch-along!
I hope you guys had a great time watching today!
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture changed, get up and move around to get that blood flowing!
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed!
Because you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time, everybody!
Bye, guys!
Bye-bye!